le bouchon monstre de samedi dernier sur
l'autoroute 20 en direction de
l'aéroport Trudeau a non seulement
irrité des centaines de voyageurs mais
il a forcé le ministère des Transports
un examen de conscience moi je chemise
et transport et ça a pas de bon sens
quand je vois des gens qui sont obligés
qui sont obligés de circuler à pied avec
leur valise sur des accotements
d'autoroute ça n'a aucun sens en
principe les automobilistes auraient dû
savoir que ce tronçon d'autoroute serait
fermé tout le week-end mais en pratique
le message ne s'est jamais rendu jusqu'à
eux si bien que le ministre s'est engagé
améliori sa plateforme Québec 51 qui
informe le public sur les travaux en
cours et à venir est suffisamment
optimale performant est-ce que
l'information est accessible en temps
réel est-ce qu'il y a eu un bug avec oui
c'est ça qu'on est en train de regarder
parce que mais on devrait agir
rapidement ce week-end il y aura
notamment des travaux majeurs dans les
tunnels Ville-Marie IVG ce qui
entraînera une fermeture complète de la
route 136 de la rue Panet jusqu'à la rue
Lucien l'Allier le trafic va donc
s'intensifier en périphérie au
centre-ville ou 70 policiers vont
assurer la fluidité des déplacements il
faut s'attendre à beaucoup de fermetures
en fin de semaine ça c'est normal mais
on s'attend pas à la même la même
intensité que dans le secteur de
l'échangeur si clair comme la fin de
semaine dernière personne nous nous
informe donc on arrive ici surprise
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle
Montréal on l'évite au maximum de son
côté la Chambre de commerce du Montréal
métropolitain a demandé au MTQ de
relancer le groupe de travail qui
jusqu'en 2018 se réunissait deux fois
par année pour coordonner les chantiers
et les communications publiques quand je
parle d'improvisation c'est qu'ensemble
lancer ses travaux ensemble mettre en
ligne quelques informations des panneaux
le long des routes puis on dit à la
population maintenant organisez-vous
en plus des tunnels villemurerie érigées
toute une série de travaux majeurs vont
entraver les circulations à Montréal cet
été ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal